nein nein nein jetzt reicht's jetzt
leute mir herzlich kommt sondern wieder
leute ich habe mich heute auf institute
und fragt welches video ich mir heute
man schon so häufig video hat reagieren
soll
und die einstimmige entscheidung von
euch war für eine neue hilfen der folge
die vor ein paar tagen leider muss man
sagen online gegangen ist allein schon
den titel zu lesen macht ein bisschen
traurig leute aber er hat sich
gewöhnlich deswegen werde ich mir das
heute angespannt die folge heißt wir
gerade seht lebensmittel machen mich und
wir bereiten uns darauf vor dass es
richtig weh tut was damit passiert
siehst du denn aus
das muss voller fahrt aufgegangen sein
und spaß zu machen und wenn dann richtig
schön gestolpert und rein getan habe man
muss einfach sagen stabile friseur geht
auf jeden fall mit dem trend der zeit
muss man sagen dass ich viel verpasst
hat trägt hier die frisur in der
variante trauerweide einfach die
strähnen bis ins gesicht so dass man
sich einfach irgendwann selbst nicht
mehr im spiegel erkennen kann das ist
heute eine veranstaltung vom
kaninchenzuchtverein die feinheit ihr
jubiläum
das ist ganz ganz wichtige kunden der
typ gilt gibt euch einfach diesen typen
leute man soll nicht zu krass
oberflächlich seien aber bei diesem typ
weiß man eigentlich schon da ist
irgendwas im busch okay also wenn jetzt
nicht aufessen steht bei den essen jetzt
nicht an macht dann muss es irgendwas
anderes wie ihr dass er einen
tintenfisch oder irgend sowas ja ein
ganz ganz viele
mit kräuter mit ihr los alles in ordnung
was okay also ich meine man kann schon
irgendwie nachvollziehen dass leute sich
für essen begeistern leute das ist ja
auch das ist ja auch normal eigentlich
sollte irgendwo beweisen sich alle leute
für essen aber dass man essen
tatsächlich findet ist eine sache mein
ok macht der dingo aber gekochtes ei mit
kräutern als den höhepunkt der
kulinarischen welt darzustellen das ist
ein verbrechen alles gut alles gut
das liegt an der frisur okay machen
folgendes therapie es hier schön die
platten dekor ist alles schön weil ich
dort auch dazu zur ausbildung der
gavotte leute habt jetzt kriegt immer
perfekt ist auch wer atmet da die ganze
zeit so schwer im hintergrund es ist der
kameramann oder soll es teil der folge
seien also mich würde auch nicht wunder
wenn es aber der kameramann ist und rtl2
sei aber nicht gecheckt hat aber er
achtet man darauf muss auch gelernt zu
machen kann man wie gesagt keine ahnung
aber okay alles da jetzt lassen sie ihn
damit dem essen alleine jiechi gut
gemacht wahrscheinlich ist dass fred
hier von fritz partyservice pro du weißt
wo du weißt du nicht wozu das führen
wird der hätte jetzt wahrscheinlich
seinen fuß in die 1
[Musik]
im hintergrund auch ganz gut
nein nein nein nein lass jetzt den fuß
in die eier
nein nein nein nein nein stopp stopp
stopp stopp rtl 2 ist nicht euer ernst
wolf mir erzählte steckt sich jetzt ein
halbes gekochtes ei in die hosentasche
geht's euch noch gut
naja leute
das kann kann doch eigentlich sein es
kann doch eigentlich nicht sein dass so
etwas existiert oder wer hat das
abgesegnet
ich will jetzt einen namen haben ich
will verantwortliche bei rtl jetzt
wissen das scheint eine ausgeprägte
libido und eine ziemlich skurrile
vorliebe für lebensmittel zu haben
der fachbegriff hierfür laut der zeitung
komplett des rest in peace auch wirklich
noch mal an die leute die das hier noch
kommentieren ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher
also in den job ich bin mir schon sich
also der die mieseste job auf dem
planeten ist hilf mir schauspieler
da gibt es eigentlich keine zweifel aber
direkt danach noch lange vor kanal
reiniger ohne schutzausrüstung kommt
hilf mir experte
was tun
a
nein nein nein ich leute ich hab ich
schon mal gemacht ich bin schon kaum aus
dem zimmer aus werden heute könnte der
erste tag fällt wo ich nicht wieder
zurückkommen und die 24 minuten endet
jungewelt es wenigstens so ein geiles t
bone steak wäre mit kräuterbutter okay
also bis ticker für rentner ja geil aber
ein halbes gekochtes ei als wasser
a
ja das war es was nicht mal auf
irgendeinen sinn er nimmt jetzt eine
hand voll wasser und wirft sich das
wasser in die hose voll dicker wem auf
der welt so dass irgendwas bringen
aufhören
eur beendet einfach
denn überhaupt aus dieses blockes level
erreicht wo er eine so wurde scheint
macht in eurem leben das ihr als ausrede
dafür benutzt dass ihr euch in die hose
gemacht habt okay das ist die ausrede
dafür das ist quasi das geringere übel
dass es weniger schlimm als das was ihr
wirklich gemacht habe ich wollte
eigentlich sagen leute aber es ist
wirklich nicht zu übersehen hätte das
müssen dem absoluten hochsommer gedreht
haben alter die arme frau keck das mal
jetzt aber diese ganze folge macht
einfach nur traurig
die stinkt ja dort hast du denn damit
gemacht nichts besonderes eigentlich
habe ich habe dann ein bisserl
reingesteckt hat es nur heimischen da
drin gelassen und danach habe ich das
halbe damit er weggeworfen
also könnten weil ich weiß jetzt nicht
warum die juni komisch riechen sollte
oder so christ
[Gelächter]
sollte er gibt sein bestes gibt sein
bestes sollte habt ihr nicht gesehen wie
er den westen jemand das ist sein erster
arbeitstag und der junge hängt sich
wirklich voll rein
der geht bis an die grenze und noch
weiter er hat an seinem ersten
arbeitstag ein tablett aus dem wagen in
einen raum rein getragen und dann sich
schon direkt in die hose gesteckt
er gibt alles scheint zu hause bei
seiner mutter nicht viel zu melden zu
haben
stopp stopp stopp muss ich direkt schon
wieder dazwischen könnten es war eine
ganz normales super rtl 2 er ist einfach
in sein zimmer rein gegangen und er
hätte ich jetzt was machen können wo
also alleine da setzt man sich selbst ja
schon und was haben wir falsch gemacht
geht natürlich nicht
wir müssen wir müssen hier wieder
übertreiben wir müssen ja eine expertin
einblenden und währenddessen im
hintergrund zeigen wie eine salami
streichelt eine gottverdammte salami
check die es noch ist die situation
extrem stark beim auftritt kann
allerdings ein anzeichen dafür sein dass
er innerlich unter enormen druck steht
ob ich würde auch unter enormen druck
stehen wir nicht so leben wollte ja habt
ihr das kann ihm gesehen ich konnte es
glaube ich nicht einbilden weil die frau
parallel so jede sachen erzählt aber er
hat gerade eben seine salami und das
kopfkissen gelegt
er schläft mit seiner salami in einem
bett liege allein der gedanke dazu
setzen wir schon unter druck
aber ich will halt alles wer sagt denn
dass wir wegen eines hier sind ich habe
so eine überraschung für dich oh mein
gott im block weiter ok seine mutter
schleppt in der eisdiele und er denkt
sie schon ewig und ices lebensmittel
könnte schief geht und es mama ich will
damit nichts zu tun haben dann zeigt
sich aber im gleichen moment dass seine
mutter ihn verkuppeln will passt auf mit
wem mit ihr das geht überhaupt nicht
mehr alter und das erinnert mich wieder
irgendwie bei als 80 mal sagen das ist
sie das moniert die kupplerin spielt ist
von ihr ja nett gemeint aber sie führt
ihren sohn regelrecht vor das gedicht
war auch so süß was du geschrieben hast
leute das ist doch keine unterhaltung ja
so was gibt mir depressionen als ein
euro jobber vorleute erstes date eure
mutter sitzt einfach mit am tisch
dann ist es nicht mal das
allerschlimmste weil darüber hinaus hat
euer date einfach noch seine augenbrauen
von angry birds sie ist wirklich ein
angry bird der gelbe angry bird da führt
kein weg daran vorbei das geht überhaupt
nicht
[Musik]
womit haben wir das verdient womit haben
wir das verdient ist das ein der
katastrophen von der in der bibel die
rede war dass die katastrophe auf die
erde kommen soll um menschen zu
bestrafen
nein nein nein jetzt reicht's jetzt halt
leute mir hier gut vorstellen könnte man
karadzics bildete aus alter